no thank you for all your straight
answers today we don't always get them
so i really appreciate it
let me ask you this one finally if i may
please minister
will you wear a mask when you go into
pret on friday if you want a takeaway
coffee
i will and i have been doing for the
last uh
few days uh keep one in my pocket one in
the car
um just to make sure that i've always
got one handy and i'll be traveling to
liverpool today to spend
time with the police there i'll be
wearing a mask all the way and do you
think that it is uh compulsory to where
i want to go into
pret well it will be compulsory to go
into a retail environment and wear one
yes
and i hope and believe that the vast
majority of the british people as they
did with all the other regulations and
lockdown will comply
see that's interesting because number 10
have told us that it won't be compulsory
and alex sharma also said that it
wouldn't be compulsory
oh okay well you've you've i suppose
you've had you got your moment there
okay
no no not tomorrow but it's not a gotcha
moment i'm literally asking on behalf of
my viewers because you know they'll be
running to grab their coffees and they
don't know the health secretary said
that it absolutely you have to wear one
it's compulsory you're saying it's
compulsory
number 10 is saying it isn't alok sharma
saying it isn't you can see why it's
confusing
well yes and obviously when i get back
to base i'll have to make sure that we
clarify
uh the message but look the key thing is
kay that the
the vast majority of the british people
realize that common sense is required
and if you're in a retail environment
like that that a mask is recommended
and obviously the regulations will come
into place on friday
it's great to talk to you we don't talk
to you often enough come back we will
never drop you from the show if you want
to come on thank you for joining us
appreciate it
thanks very much bye-bye